5 55 on your monday morning got a viewer
complaint from someone who would know
about dangerous drivers around school
buses viewer brian writes he's a school
bus driver and he sets the stage for us
by writing that on las vegas boulevard
and saint rose parkway in the two left
turn lanes to go west on saint rose from
las vegas boulevard cars in that inside
turn lane he says they're cutting off
school buses and other cars by jumping
into that lane that goes to the north
15. he says because of that there have
been several school bus crashes at the
intersection and he writes i think we
need some traffic enforcement in the
area sounds like a good idea brian i'll
pass your email onto the nevada highway
patrol but this is a great opportunity
to remind all of us that even if a bus
is empty coming out of the yard near
there it's on its way to carry our most
precious cargo
young people on their way to or from
school so if you're going to be a jerky
driver can you at least leave school
buses out of your dangerous behavior
thank you buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone something's
driving you crazy email me traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com